>>> George Santos is under
investigation by the FBI for
allegedly stealing $3,000 from a
dying dog's gofundme.
The dog's owner and Navy veteran
said that FBI investigated him
and they're elated that they're
investigating.
Santos is not worried as he
dodged questions though about
the federal investigation.
>> Are you concerned about the
FBI investigation?
>> I am not.
>> Have you spoken to him?
>> Mr. Santos?
You're facing a federal
investigation here.
This is very serious.
Can you explain to your voters
and your constituents what
happened with this veteran?
The conversations that you had
with him?
Mr. Santos?
>> Santos not answering
questions there.
But the dog's owner did speak to
don last month about the
incident and what happened.
>> This guy, he doesn't deserve
to be where he's at.
He doesn't deserve a government
pension.
But when I saw him on the news,
I put two and two together.
It ripped the scab off and felt
like my dad died yesterday.
It hurt me that much again.
I don't want you to hurt anybody
like you hurt me again, George.
Nobody should have to go through
that.
I almost killed myself when that
dog died.
That's why I'm here.
I don't want him to be able to
do this again.
>> And he joins us now with the
founder of the New Jersey
veterans network that tried to
intervene and help get the money
there.
Thank you both for joining us
back again.
That was such a powerful
interview that you had with don
and so much happened since then
including the FBI reaching out
to you.
What were the questions for you?
>> I can't really get into the
exact details about the
questions they asked.
I did, however, provide them
every piece of evidence that
they needed.
I don't have anything to hide
from them.
I want them to pursue this.
He didn't just break the law.
He broke my heart when he did
this.
I don't usually like to go after
people and have them get in
trouble or anything like that.
But you break the law, and you
break my heart, and you put me
through something like this
where I thought that I was going
to have my dog taken care of and
then I just had to sit there and
watch her die and I couldn't do
anything about it.
>> And from being there, are you
surprised from being many that
moment when she did pass away,
are you surprised it came from
there to now the FBI is actually
looking into this?
Are you glad?
>> I contacted my local law
enforcement when it first
happened.
They didn't have a clue who he
was, where he was at or
anything.
So now the feds picked it up.
I know it is still prosecutable
at this point.
I was so relieved.
And just speaking to the FBI the
little bit that I did was
cathartic.
I mean just to get my emotions
out there and know this is going
somewhere.
>> Did they want text messages,
phone calls?
>> Text messages.
They wanted screen shots of
anything I had from the gofundme
campaign and off of my Facebook.
>> Yeah.
The former deputy director said
given that it is $3,000 is not
typically something the FBI
would look into, he means there
say broader scope of activity
that Santos is involved in.
Is that your suspicion as well?
>> I would put money on it.
I'm not the only one he's done
this to.
It was so well lubricated and
smoothed the way he did
everything and the talk he had.
It came out so smooth and
readily -- didn't -- it was
rehearsed.
And as far as the $3,000 is
concerned, too, I'm not really
looking to get that back from
him.
I don't really think even if he
had a judgement against him to
pay it, I don't think I'd ever
see it anyway.
George Santos screwed me over
but I've been getting a lot of
positive feedback from people
and America is making it right.
>> George Santos was asked about
not just this incident but all
of the broader lies that have
been uncovered since he ran for
office.
>> I know a lot of people want
to create this narrative that I
faked my twi congress.
That is false.
I worked hard.
I built ground up a career
through experience and through
knowledge and through self
education.
And, you know, I think it's
amazing I have to sit here and
being spoken down to on a
regular basis yet again by the
media.
>> What do you make of those
comments?
>> I'm amazed that he's actually
in a position that he got into.
I don't understand how he wasn't
vetted out properly.
I mean, thing dozen happen.
I understand that.
It's crazy that this person is
at the position he is right now.
And he has the possibility of
passing legislation.
I'm shocked.
And once I found out who he was,
it's hurtful to know that.
This is the person who
representing our country.
>> He still a lawmaker.
He did step down from the
committees.
He is still in congress.
What do you make of him saying
that he's worked hard.
He built up this career and
talking about being spoken down
to by the media.
>> He should have had a career
as a stand up comic.
He needs to get out of the
spotlight.
Step down and get out right now.
He's just being a distraction.
Everything that he's doing --
everything that he's done, it's
a circus.
It's a media circus behind him.
And it's making our government
look bad.
It really is.
He needs to go.
And that's probably the way he
can say he's sorry better than
any other way.
>> What does it say to you that
he's not answering questions
about any of these allegations?
>> He's heartless and has no
moral come pass and no shame.
No remorse.
He's like a super villain.
>> Does he owe you a public
apology?
>> I believe so.
I believe so.
At least acknowledgement that he
remembers me and remembers that
this happened.
>> Thank you, Michael.
I know this is painful thing for
you to talk about and to bring